[Music]
in bad idea news I have a lot of those
oh yeah so do I bowling shoes with
wheels on the bottom
yes skates what help but they're for
bowling oh they are skis that's like the
bowling shoes yeah yeah those are
training shoes to help you learn a ball
better
oh that's pretty good a good idea you
like that submitted by El Diablo
that Devil a couple was arrested for
locking their toddler in the trunk of
their car for a social experiment what
do you think it is it yeah either you do
a bunch of sadists and they're like
social experiment it's a social
experiment bro right I mean that's the
third thing what's the experiment to see
if we can traumatize this kid for the
rest of his life
all right are they Hitler cuz that's
what he would do cuz I just want to know
what type of scientists you guys are
like are they sociology [ __ ]
professors are like what's going on or
like McDonald's line cooks yeah you know
no with the passion in a social
experiment we give our kid dissociative
identity disorder mm-hmm
that's an interesting social experiment
I thought you gotta say nowadays it was
an experiment
yeah why'd you rob that liquor store
social experiment yep what doesn't
matter is like when that one big star
like sexually assaulted a bunch of girls
of those like a social experiment Sam
pepper right yeah oh god that was a fun
one
we just grabbed all her but something
he's like yeah I forgot about Sam pepper
I was a fun one
oh and he like hid his pan and the thing
yeah and then you grab there but yeah
anyway so this okay hey there you told
police that they were conducting a
social experiment to raise awareness
about speaking up and taking action when
a child is in danger so they put their
two year old two year old
on this kids
[ __ ] this is traumatize really and they
locked him in the trunk of a car
oh no well I bet you they went viral
though they could I just had a dummy
with the sounds of a two-year-old in a
tape recorder oh why didn't you tell on
us that's a good idea
but you know with all the faint fake
pranks nowadays they want to be
authentic that's right for that they
want to be authentic they kept it real
good abuse fines yeah so what they were
saying so the dad was saying that he
they put the back seat down so the kid
could breathe and the mom was in the
back seat so the kid could be like be
with the mom okay but that people
couldn't see that and that's what he was
claiming Oh someone took a photo kid in
the trunk very safely putting him in the
truck okay there's a very good reason
why I was doing this to my kid all over
town because they were going multiple
places and doing this how do you go
viral
you know controversy man they didn't
mention it if this is being filmed
though who's he holding a camera in that
he filmed there's no way people what
then why even have it I hope is that kid
two years old like it literally is five
yeah kid there's a very tall two year oh
yeah yeah I mean the photo that maybe
he's like from the Dominican Republic
those kids are big man he's actually
gonna be an Olympic athlete later
adopted a Samoan yeah I've never seen a
two-year-old that large before that one
was almost testicle as me yeah but yeah
so they're saying that that day it
reached close to 90 degrees like what
the hell why they believe this little
boy in the trunk and so they were saying
that there were so many people that
passed by and that no one ever said
anything and so
one woman called the police and the
police yeah it's called the bystander
effect or something it's already been
proven they do that all the [ __ ] time
there's even a lady that was like raped
and [ __ ] public and everyone just
walked by yeah and then you know it's
because a lot of people are scared so
these people who did the social
experiment the lady who called the cops
is what they're looking for right pretty
much right on then it worked
yeah after like thousands of people
probably but you know but they're like
we're good parents you know like we we
take care of him it's just that we were
using him for his social experiment
that's not a good parent then because
yeah I thought that it was common
knowledge that children don't have the
ability to kind of separate real and be
right until like aged seven plus so and
then and then you're like 30 years old
and you're wondering why you cry all the
time and shaking at night and then you
go to a therapist office and they're
like look maybe there was some childhood
trauma and you're like I can't remember
cuz I blocked it out it sounds so real
yeah and then and then your husband has
to have violent sex with you for you to
get off just sounds like a story I heard
I love car trunks I thought it was
awesome to jump inside the trunk I
begged my mom was like we were going to
the store I'm like please can I write in
the trunk please she's like no I'm gonna
go to jail and I'm like I just think I
would not stop bugging her she finally
let me you know I was like according to
Joe just now that's a bad parent I know
right I think it's a good parent if it's
something you want to do you know how we
used to be able to ride in the back of
pickup trucks yeah I miss that you
should you could do that you could do
that of Hawaii oh yeah you can also
drive barefoot in Hawaii whereas you
can't do that here but also the speed
limit there's like 30 miles per hour
yeah it's pretty nicer man it's super
slow barefoot it feels weird no it's
gone man wait you can't drive barefoot
here why how do they tell you how do
they take that I don't know you do it
all the time
I've done a couple of times it's really
like I'll take my high heels off like it
does kind of feel I don't know it feels
get the press harder well you didn't
grow up on a beach town then okay
solutely man it's just like and it makes
sense in Hawaii because they could saw
the whole town as a beach town can you
put your Santa Barbara I would drive
barefoot all the time
can you drive and illegal yeah it's the
same thing it's different cuz I feel
like without it yet the press your yep
usual press down more versus the shoe is
so clunky you could just lightly press
it down oh I use my um the ball of my
foot you you you're you drive with the
ball your foot you are like no nothing
else yeah it's like this part the ball
Wow
you press the pedal with your feet with
the [ __ ] but this happened today not
this not the situation but I was walking
by a t-mobile on the day that the iPhone
10s came out and I see these two kids
like jiggling with the with the door
it's like what do i do right now do i
try to stop them or call the cops or
just kick them but what do they have a
gun well you wouldn't be there jiggle on
the door there they're trying to break
into somebody's car you know into the
t-mobile store where they had 10 iPhone
10 in the back oh maybe they're just
working there but they didn't
how young did they look I don't know
because they were like kind of jiggling
it and then it was like 10 p.m. when
they was already closed well for me I
would not have said anything because
number one it's a corporate store so I
don't give a [ __ ]
if it's a mom-and-pop a different story
wouldn't fight I'll be like and they
turn around I'll be like I did my job
yeah I made a scene yes now everybody's
looking I don't know if I saw a kid
getting stuffed into a trunk it depends
on if the kid was like screaming and
crying maybe I would call the cops or
something but if it was just a kid being
put in the trunk and the kids like boom
bet I'd be like the man that sucks
oh no just recently the other day I was
at Crystal Cove and this guy was getting
his dick sucked on the beach and there I
thought your answer is
so I just started talking really loud
and then he just started playing dead so
I saw some of the head was there so
anyway get over her but you see her a
head bobbing it's a beach you know I
mean like come on it's people are
there's a blanket over the kid can't see
nothing just like making jokes super
line eventually stuff like you think
David gets offended by a blanket going
like that the wind
that's pretty offensive stuff there find
a highly offensive where her legs I pick
something it's like you know the [ __ ]
in your story it didn't look just like a
blanket they did but that it's pretty
like it was pretty graphic because when
David sees a water bed like rippling
like that he calls the cops
he gets absolutely no you doesn't call
the cops he makes the scene he goes hi I
won't [ __ ] a dirty bathroom now what
is going so I won't [ __ ] dirty
bathrooms and she wants to [ __ ] in a
dirty bag you don't want to you do want
to don't want but you do want to who are
we talking to yesterday
oh and we're like we would [ __ ] he was
[ __ ] of cols I just found out because
here's the thing about that like would
you would you [ __ ] a target dressing
room he's like that's not bad I'm like
no way I shop at Target I don't want to
get bad from there you go to Cole's
because getting banned from Cole's would
actually be an honor why cuz you never
go in there hey you know it's like
clothes for like it's like dad where for
kids
there goes articles sponsorships other
things things you got a brand deal from
there Oh
I don't know yeah you did I never been
inside one well so if you see us in two
calls you know what there's one reason
why you ever walked in who is it like
Sears what is it like it's like a nicer
JC Penney's but like by that much I
thought it was a hardware store no
absolutely not it's filthy and
disgusting
OHL wouldn't you do it if you simulated
it with pretend dirt or like you created
your own bathroom just man I've ever
heard my thing my thing is like we could
get cut that's what's sexy about it how
dirty it is right you don't catch dirty
not dirt though with urine but you want
car urine thank you I'll do that
not if not yeah no I don't want to get
caught urine is what makes it for you
know behind the urine because of this
rush of maybe getting caught yeah so I
it's not that I like the urine part it's
the like it's like I wish is there
somewhere else that you guys can
compromise where it's the same feeling
of what we're trying exactly the
dressing room I think once we've
compromised or just having sex on a
cruise ships that kind of counts yeah
can you go to Cole's we know what you're
up to
he mentioned being a kid who Shops at
Cole's and then like you walking in the
dressing room like that's the worst
afternoon you know what he's already
having a bad time cuz he's at Cole's
and then he just has another bed another
bad time during school hours so no
little kids will be there only the only
the bad kids will be there yeah oh then
there's no about you
to where calls Yorick holes no kids who
wear clothes clothing look like to have
briefcases and beepers and [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]